Am 13.
Januar 2018, bekamen alle Bewohner der US-amerikanischen
Insel Hawaii dieselbe Warnung auf ihr Smartphone:
“Katastrophenalarm.
Ballistische Rakete im Anflug auf Hawaii.
Suchen Sie sofort Unterschlupf.
Dies ist kein Test.”
Ähnliche Warnungen ertönten an diesem Samstagmorgen
auch aus Fernsehern und Radios.
Innerhalb von wenigen Minuten brach bei vielen
Menschen auf der Insel Panik aus.
Die allerwenigsten wussten, was zu tun war,
wo man sich in Sicherheit bringen konnte.
Viele telefonierten ein womöglich letztes
Mal mit ihren Familien auf dem Festland.
Es herrschte Chaos.
13 Minuten nach der ursprünglichen Meldung
kamen die ersten Entwarnungen von offizieller
Seite.
Es gibt gar keinen Angriff auf Hawaii.
Diese Nachrichten verbreiteten sich zuerst
über Facebook und Twitter.
Erst 38 Minuten nach der ersten Nachricht
auf die Smartphones kam eine Entwarnung über
dasselbe System: Falscher Alarm.
Doch der Schaden war bereits angerichtet.
Viele Menschen hatten Angst, manche richtige
Panikattacken und sogar Herzinfarkte.
Einige bedauern im Nachhinein, wie sie sich
in dieser halben Stunde verhalten haben.
Manche haben ihrem Chef unschöne Dinge gesagt,
andere haben sich nicht getraut ihre Geliebten
auf den Festland anzurufen und machen sich
nun Vorwürfe.
Nachdem bekannt wurde, dass der Alarm nur
ein Fehler war, wurden natürlich sofort Stimmen
laut: Wie konnte so ein massiver und folgenschwerer
Fehlalarm überhaupt gesendet werden?
Die Antwort hat mit Design zu tun.
Das mag jetzt vielleicht einige von euch überraschen,
aber selbst das US-amerikanische Militär
benutzt mehr oder weniger normale Computer.
Auch die Katastrophenmeldungen, die an millionen
Handys, Fernseher und Radios in einem bestimmten
Gebiet gesendet werden, werden von
einem Computerprogramm kontrolliert.
Dieses Programm wurde allerdings schlecht
designt.
Wie in den Untersuchungen nach dem Vorfall
herauskam, wählt ein Soldat in der Praxis
aus einen ganz normalen Drop-Down-Menü aus,
welche Sorte Alarm er haben möchte.
Den Test-Alarm für Übungen, oder den echten
Alarm, Live.
Es gibt nach dieser Auswahl noch mehrere Seiten,
auf denen man seine Auswahl bestätigen muss,
diese unterscheiden sich aber visuell nicht
vom Test-Alarm.
Wenn sich also jemand zu Beginn verklickt
und sich danach nicht jeden Textblock intensiv
durchliest, dann sieht er womöglich keinen
Unterschied zwischen dem Test, der keine Folgen
hat und der echten Katastrophenwarnung, die
an Millionen Menschen raus geht.
Aber die Sache ist noch ein bisschen komplizierter
als das.
Denn obwohl offizielle Berichte unter anderem
dem Software-Programm die Schuld für den
Vorfall geben, behauptet der Soldat, der den
Alarm ausgelöst hat, dass er bewusst den
echten Alarm ausgelöst hat.
Bei einem außerplanmäßigen Übungs-Anruf
am Samstagmorgen hatte er zu Beginn des Anrufs
nicht gehört, dass es sich um einen Übungs-Anruf
handelte.
Der Soldat dachte also, dass Hawaii wirklich
angegriffen wird.
Die ganze Prozedur hat also mehrere Design-Fehler.
Design meint hier nicht, ob die Schrift Schnörkel
hat oder welche Farben schöner aussehen,
sondern wie die Benutzung gestaltet ist.
Dass zum einen nicht immer klar ist, welchen
Alarm man gerade auslöst und zum anderen
Warnungen weder von dieser noch von höherer
Stelle gestoppt werden können.
Auch die Tatsache, dass es 38 Minuten gedauert
hat eine Entwarnung zu senden, ist Hinweis
für ein schlecht designtes Kommunikations-System.
Tatsächlich wurde alles, was von Menschen
gemacht wurde, designt.
Jede Tür, jede Kaffeetasse und jede Waschmaschine
wurde konzipiert.
Und wenn man sich erstmal bewusst macht, dass
sich Menschen intensiv damit beschäftigt
haben, wie ein Gegenstand benutzt werden sollte,
dann fällt einem auch auf, wie häufig Dinge
schlecht designt sind.
Türen sind ein super Beispiel.
Wie oft kommt es vor, dass ihr an einer Tür
zieht, anstatt sie aufzudrücken?
Eine gute designte Tür kann von jedem Menschen
intuitiv richtig geöffnet und geschlossen
werden.
Sie braucht keine Hinweisschilder mit “Drücken”
oder “Ziehen”.
Wenn eine Tür einem gar keine andere Möglichkeit
bietet, an ihr zu ziehen, dann drückt
man automatisch.
Gut designte Gegenstände können von Menschen
intuitiv richtig verwendet werden.
Sie brauchen keine Bedienungsanleitungen oder
Hinweisschilder.
Ein guter Designer stellt den Menschen in
den Mittelpunkt und verhindert, dass man das
Objekt falsch verwenden kann.
Wird das Objekt dennoch falsch verwendet,
dann hat der Designer versagt, nicht der Nutzer.
Das sind einige der Prinzipien von “Human
Centered”, also menschenzentriertem Design.
Und das wird immer wichtiger, je komplexer
die Gegenstände werden, die wir verwenden.
Dein Handy ist inzwischen zum Beispiel eine
Foto- und Filmkamera, eine Schreibmaschine,
eine Karte mit Kompass, dein Zugang zum Internet
und jetzt gerade ein Fernseher.
Dass wir all diese unterschiedlichen Funktionen
inzwischen intuitiv bedienen können ist der
Verdienst jahrzehntelanger Forschung und Entwicklung
auf Seite der Hersteller und jahrelanger Übung
von uns.
Aber auch die Sprache der Smartphones muss
erst einmal gelernt werden.
Etwas, dass zumindest ich immer wieder merke,
wenn mich meine Eltern fragen, wie man ein
Update runterlädt oder mehr Speicherplatz
frei macht.
Aber dabei ist doch das eigentlich nicht Sinn
der Sache.
Nicht wir sollten die Sprache der Smartphones lernen, sondern die Maschinen
sollten unsere Sprache lernen.
Man nennt das Humanization of Tech, die die
Vermenschlichung von Technologien.
Das Ziel ist hier, dass sich Mensch und Maschine
so unterhalten können, wie wir Menschen es
untereinander tun.
Das soll Reibungspunkte minimieren.
Wie viele ältere Menschen sagen: “Ach,
dieses Internet.
Das ist nichts für mich.” und lehnen damit
einen riesigen Berg an Informationen, Unterhaltung
und sozialen Kontakten ab, weil das Bedienen
eines Computers zu kompliziert ist.
Das Tippen auf den Smartphone-Bildschirm ist
zwar schon intuitiver, als das Schreiben auf
einer Tastatur, aber immer noch nicht menschlich.
Wenn Menschen sich unterhalten, dann benutzen
sie dabei ihre Stimme, ihre Hände und Gesichtsausdrücke.
Und an all diesen Eingabemethoden wird gerade
geforscht.
Google hat zum Beispiel gerade das erste Smartphone
mit einem Radar-Chip veröffentlicht.
Das aktuelle Gerät kann zwar noch nicht viel
mehr, als das Wischen einer Hand erkennen,
aber die Technologie ist zu deutlich mehr
im Stande.
Das zeigt auch die Autoindustrie, wo man nur
mit Gesten schon die Lautstärke, das Navi
und eine 360°-Kamera steuern kann.
Und auch Microsofts Hololens hat schon gezeigt,
dass der Einsatz der Hände einfach die natürlichste
Art und Weise ist mit Gegenständen zu hantieren.
Mithilfe von Machine Learning können Computer
mit einer simplen Webcam inzwischen auch Gesichtsausdrücke
erkennen.
Wobei das Interpretieren dieser noch Schwierigkeiten
bereitet.
In einer Studie im Auftrag der Association
for Psychological Science haben 5 Forscher
2 Jahre lang die Komplexität von Emotionen
und deren Gesichtsausdrücke analysiert.
Das Ergebnis: Es gibt extrem viele verschiedene
Arten von Emotionen und oft werden diese durch
sehr unterschiedliche Gesichtsausdrücke zum
Ausdruck gebracht.
Wütende Menschen machen zum Beispiel nur
zu 30% der Zeit ein finsteres Gesicht.
Und noch schlimmer: Wir machen auch finstere
Gesichter, wenn wir gar nicht wütend sind.
Eine Künstliche Intelligenz zur Erkennung
von Emotionen hat da erst mal Schwierigkeiten
durchzublicken.
Mal davon abgesehen, dass jeder Mensch auch
noch individuell ist und seine eigene Persönlichkeit
zum Ausdruck bringt.
Über Mimik, aber auch über die Stimme.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich die größte Herausforderung
bei unserer Aufgabe Technologie menschlich
zu machen.
Verstehen können uns Maschinen schon recht
gut, da haben wir Dank Machine Learning in
den letzten Jahren riesige Fortschritte gemacht.
Und auch sprechen können die Assistenten
schon sehr überzeugend.
Im Mai 2018 stellte Google das neue Feature
des Assistenten vor, der für dich Termine
beim Friseur machen kann und dabei wie ein
echter Mensch klingt.
Google:,,Hi, ich rufe an um einen Frauen Haarschnitt für unsere Klientin zu buchen!
Ich suche nach etwas am 3. Mai."
Aber was nach wie vor schwierig für Computer
ist, ist den Kontext zu verstehen.
Es ist leicht bestimmte Befehle in den Code
einzuprogrammieren.
Wenn der User fragt: Was ist X + Y, dann addiere
die beiden Zahlen und sag ihm das Ergebnis.
Aber Menschen stellen in echten Gesprächen
selten solche Fragen.
Vielmehr sind Gespräche ein Wirrwarr aus
Redewendungen, Verweisen auf ältere Gespräche
und kleinen Insidern.
Bis ein Computer da mitkommt, wird es noch
ein wenig dauern.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch erst mal zu viel
gewollt.
Ich muss mich ja nicht tiefgründig mit meinem
Computer unterhalten.
Toll wäre es erst mal, wenn wir uns nicht
missverstehen.
Wie hätte man also den den Fehlalarm auf
Hawaii verhindern können?
Nun, das Computerprogramm war schlecht designt
und wurde als eine Fehlerquelle identifiziert.
Kurz nach dem Vorfall wurde bekanntgegeben,
dass einige Veränderungen an der Software
vorgenommen werden, sodass nun deutlicher
wird, wenn man im Begriff ist einen echten
Alarm auszulösen.
Hoffentlich nicht nur mit Text, sondern auch
mit Warn-Farben und vielleicht einem Signalton.
Etwas, das Menschen besser intuitiv verstehen.
Auch gibt es nun die Möglichkeit den Alarm
zurückzurufen, wenn man ihn fälschlicherweise
abgeschickt hat.
Aber wirklich sicher ist das auch noch nicht.
Was wirklich helfen könnte, ist dass von
nun an zwei Menschen benötigt werden, um
einen Katastrophenalarm auszusenden.
So müssen immer erst einmal zwei Menschen
miteinander kommunizieren und sich verständigen,
bevor ein Alarm gesendet werden kann.
Denn wie so oft ist die größte Fehlerquelle
immer noch der Mensch.
Dieses Video wurde unterstützt von Merck.
Merck ist ein Wissenschafts- und Technologieunternehmen
und möchte uns alle im Rahmen der Neugier-Initiative
neugieriger machen, um Innovation und Fortschritt
zu fördern.
Auf der Website von Worlds of Curiosity kann
man sich ansehen, warum Neugier so wichtig
ist und wie sie zu einer besseren Welt führt.
Dabei begleitet man eine Wissenschaftlerin/Forscherin
durch ihren Tag.
Wie sie zur Arbeit kommt, wie sie arbeitet
und wie sie ihre Freizeit verbringt.
In allen Bereichen verstecken sich viele Informationen
zu Zukunftstechnologien mit Interviews und
interessanten Texten.
Humanization of Tech ist dort auch ein Thema.
Immanuel Schweizer hat ein sehr spannendes
Interview zu dem Thema gegeben.
Schaut’s euch gerne mal, wenn ihr das Thema
spannend findet.
Einen Link dazu habe ich euch in die Videobeschreibung
gepackt.
Vielen Dank an Merck für die Unterstützung
bei diesem Video und Danke an euch für’s
Zuschauen.
Wie immer bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.